ich weiß nicht ob sie meine damen und
herren etwas bereuen in ihrem leben
ich meinerseits bereue manchmal dass ich
bis jetzt noch nicht mehr musik gemacht
habe was ich nicht die geduld hatte
einfach mehr zu üben auf meiner geige
und richtig gut zu werden auf diesem
instrument denn ein instrument zu
beherrschen
die musik von innen heraus zu
durchdringen das bewundere ich schauen
sie entsprechend bin ich gespannt auf
mein heutiges gespräch mit einem der
bedeutendsten musiker unserer zeit zu
gast bei mir in genf ist heute daniel
barenboim
er gibt als pianist konzerte seit er
sieben jahre alt ist und er dirigiert
die allerbesten orchester dieser welt
herzlich willkommen
welche bilder er bauen wollen sie
schreiben in diesem buch klang ist leben
die macht der musik dass man über musik
eigentlich gar nicht sprechen könnte da
habe ich mich gefragt worüber sollen wir
uns denn jetzt eine stunde unterhalten
über die tatsache dass man kann über
musik recht sprechen und warum es so ist
weil wenn wir über musik sprechen
sprechen wir eigentlich über unsere
reaktion zu der musik wir sind in
anatolischen laune klingt uns das stück
man college hören wir das gleiche stück
jede gleiche aufführung wenn wir heute
sind klingt die musik auch heute so
meint ich und genau damit sind sie
eigentlich beim gleichen thema das ich
vorschlagen wollte für unser gespräch
ich wollte nämlich gerne mal mit ihnen
darüber nachdenken was es eigentlich
heißt zu hören um zuzuhören weil musik
und hören gehören ja ganz eng zueinander
es ist eigentlich interessant weil ich
finde die deutsche sprache so präzise
und so reich und wunderbar eigentlich
aber auf diesem gebiet ist es nicht so
deutlich wie auf englisch wo es gibt
einen unterschied zwischen zu listen an
to hear you can hear you can listen nord
hier als deutsche ist es nun zwischen
hören und zuhören
das ist nicht so ganz passt
und wir leben hier sind eine welt wo man
eigentlich viel zu wenig richtig zuhört
muss man auch nicht muss man auch musik
zu hören
die heutige welt man hat musik im
restaurant im flugzeug im aufzug und
manchmal auch sogar das ist völlig am
schlimmsten
klassische musik und das hört man sich
wenn sie raus zu fahren oder in einen
supermarkt
dann hören sie nicht zu sie haben mal
gesagt das sei für sie manchmal eine
physische penetration diese
dauerberieselung im lift beispielsweise
damit haben sie richtig auch probleme ja
ja alles ist klar um musik zu genießen
um von musik vielleicht was besonders zu
bekommen sehr ich ja muss man eigentlich
dass ich dafür konzentrieren muss man
zuhören das was man zwar mit bekommt das
ist es nicht das ist es nicht nur wir
sind viel viel einmal eine augen
gesellschaft geworden als ein ohren
gesichert interessant ist ja auch dass
man sehr bewusst wegsehen kann wir
können die augen schließen
beispielsweise den kopf drehen
aber man kann schlecht weghören eben das
ist das ist eigentlich das alles viel
stärker ich finde auch gehör gedicht ist
viel stärker als augen gesicht ist das
kann auch kommen von der sache dass ich
eigentlich musiker wenn nicht aber zum
beispiel wenn ich klavierspielen und
habe einen moment zweifel das gedächtnis
pcs weil ich auswendig spielen und ich
mich konzentriere und höhere in meinen
ihnen was der nächste ton denn ich nicht
im moment nicht sozusagen zur verfügung
habe kommt es dann und die ganze
erfahrung von musik ist
auch für den sucher ist gedächtnis sehr
wichtig in dem moment dass sie damals
nach dem zweiten mal erwartet dass so
dass es immer so weitergeht und das ist
diese wunderbare moment von
überraschungen der musik wo das nächste
mal eine sendung kommt sei es eine
rhythmische haben sich etwas im ist eine
andere
etwas anderes ist und da sofort in der
konzentration da warum weil das so hat
eigentlich erwartet dass es weiter so
geht und es geht anders und das ist das
ist schon so zusammengestellt die erste
erfahrung von musik zusammen ja auch man
soll eben musik nicht einfach hören
sondern man soll ja wirklich zuhören was
passiert denn genau wenn jede musik zu
hören
was ist anders als wenn wir einfach
musik hören sagen wir zum abschied sind
wir kommen nach hause und mache ein
bisschen shoppen ja das ist nicht
schlimm ist aber nichts ist ja oft es
ist nichts schlimmes daran
man stellt sich vor ein besonders
schlechter tag wo man stets auf man hat
schlecht geschlafen cafés rückhalt beim
frühstück wird es nicht gut ist alt und
trocken
man geht die büro man hat probleme mit
mitarbeiter dann hat beim termin beim
steuerberater dann geht man zum zahnarzt
und da zu sehen und so also so ein tag
und da komme nach hause und man tut wie
sie sagen ein lob an option man hört es
und man ist gleich entspannt und so und
warum nicht ist ja nicht schlimm ist
daran aber man kann mich nicht
überzeugen dass alle die komponisten
bach mozart beethoven chopin brahms
wagner schönberg bull ist wie die alle
heißen
musik geschrieben haben so dass wir uns
entspannen können weil es uns schlecht
geht ist man ist muss doch in der musik
eine aussage geben und diese aussage ist
sehr wichtig und diese aussage ist
anders für jeder mensch und die hört man
nur wenn man wirklich zurück dass sich
auseinandersetzt ist sie sonst wie bei
meinem buch liest muss man sich auch
konzern zählen muss man man kann nicht
einfach lesen ohne zu denken und das ist
eigentlich selten geworden in unserer
heutigen zeit dass in einem konzertsaal
bei ereignet sich ja eigentlich etwas
unerhört dass die menschen hören zu und
sie tun nur das in aller regel sie essen
nicht dazu sie sind nicht gleichzeitig
um bügeln oder verschickten keine
e-mails oder checken auf twitter wer
wieder irgendeine nachricht geschickt
hat sondern sie sitzen da konzentrieren
sich ist eigentlich fast schon
anachronistisch in unserer zeit
vielleicht ist es schade dass ist
anachronistisch ist vielleicht sollten
wir mehrere möglichkeit haben uns mal
von einem handy und von den twitter und
social media uns so entfernen ich meine
es ist wenn man denkt heute ist es fast
unmöglich ein gespräch wenn jemand zu
führen oder dass etwas gegen gleich
liest oder schreibt und und dann wenn
man jemand sieht dass man soll ja es war
foto meine wie sie total von diesen
kleinen gerückt abhängig und das finde
ich schade
die technologie muss ja so entwickelt
sein wie nur möglich mehr und mehr kann
nicht genug sein
aber wir mussten müssen immer lernen sie
zu benutzen
ich erinnere mich als das fernsehen
wirklich am anfang erst angefangen hat
wichtig zu werden so habe viele leute
die was verträglich die kinder werden
ihre hausaufgaben nicht machen weil
alles ob das gerät vom felsen schuld
daran weil man es ist der mensch der die
verantwortung
die eltern müssen die verantwortung
nehmen dass die kinder die hausaufgaben
und sagen du kannst ab so viel ab sechs
so kannst du fernseher gucken und nicht
schon um 2 und solche sachen aber wir
wir sind viel besser bei der entwicklung
der technologie
wenn man denkt wie die technologie sich
entwickelt hat den letzten hundert jahre
ist ja unglaublich wie das leben sich
verändert hat so aber wie sie die welt
viel weniger gut die technologie dann zu
beherrschen
daher ist fast schon ein bisschen auch
den pädagogen daniel barenboim ist ja
auch die bildung sehr wichtig die
musikalische erziehung von kindern
beispielsweise ich bin nicht so jemand
gesagt früher war besser für was so
schöner olivenöl
das ist überhaupt nicht meine sache aber
eine sache war früher
ich glaube sagen wir logischer nämlich
dass musik ein organischer teil der
bildung war weil jemand der sich für
picasso interessiert hat konnte auch
sein sawinski und derjenige der paul
klee siebte warm angezogen von der musik
von schönberg zum beispiel oder sowas
dass ich will damit sagen musik war ein
organischer teil in der bildung heute
kann man ein sehr gebildeter mensch sein
viel wissen natürlich beruflich
rechtsanwalt oder hat so viel über
literatur über politik über theater
vielleicht ein bisschen über malerei
wissen und so uni ein ton musik gehört
haben
es ist ein großartiger musiker mit einem
unglaublichen talent ich bin nur eine
person die gerne musik hört gerne musik
zu hört mich gerne damit
auseinandersetze das heißt wir teilen
die leidenschaft vielleicht für musik
aber was würden sie sagen fehlt denn
einer person die kein empfinden hat für
musiker sie haben jetzt beschrieben ein
arzt ein jurist könnte großartig werden
in seinem fach ohne je musikalische
bildung
genossen zu haben das fehlt dieser
person
ja ich finde die musik kann unser leben
bereichern und in unterschiedlicher art
und weise
das ist abhängig von der mensch eine ist
vielleicht ein besinnlicher mensch und
ist beeindruckt und bereichert durch die
sinnlichkeit der musik der andere hat
eine sensibilität für fragen und man
kann dann plötzlich auch farben hören
der musik wenn ein sänger oder einen
tiger die phrase macht eine änderung die
die phrasierung
das nennt man auch eine eine andere
farbe hat er sich nicht so haben spielen
sehen sie haben wenn sie spielen sie
personal musik graviert sowieso erster
sicht ein sehr interessanter instrument
sie können ihr gewicht ich würde diese
claas triebel nun auf die tasten und das
würde ein klang machen nicht besonders
schön und es einfach der klang ist schon
da bei einem geige oder ein cello oder
auch ein blasinstrument müssen sie den
trank erziehen das heißt das klavier ist
ein neues instrument das gewicht vor dem
glas produziert einklang die will ich
wesentlich weniger interessant ist als
der klang von also robles sein aber es
ist ein klang und es ist genau diese
neutralität dass uns die listen die
möglichkeit gibt unterschiedliche farben
zu machen
das ist wie eine eine weiße wand und
eine farbige wand wenn sie eine frage
haben der weiß ist können sie am anfang
ist es total uninteressant weil es sie
so blass aber da können sie so viele
farben und sie sind immer in verbindung
damit wenn sie eine gelbe oder blaue
wand haben dann haben sie sich schon
eine bestimmte farbe und müssen sie
sozusagen damit immer rechnen das heißt
die neutralität und die tatsache dass es
ein interessantes instrument ist gibt
uns die möglichkeit es setze sich mehr
interessant machen als viele andere so
mental ist schon ein gelenk lang haben
sie haben ja schon mit sieben konzerte
gegeben den großen konzerten sie galten
als wunderkind haben sie das klavier für
sich persönlich gewählt damals hatten
sie den eindruck das ist mein instrument
ist ja eigentlich viel viel einfacher
als das alles als ich vier war hat mein
vater winter gespielt wird ein geiger
und ich habe gesagt wie später gespielt
weil ich wollte mit papa spielen
ich war sehr klein und die konnten keine
kleine gruppe war auch ein achtel lage
war zu klein für mich und dann habe ich
das vergessen und dann ein jahr später
hat mein vater gespielt zwei klaviere
und ein kollege
da habe ich gesehen man kann mit papa
spielen und dann angeblich ich kann mich
daran nicht erinnern weil meine mutter
hat das immer wiederholt wenn ich zu ihr
gegangen und habe gesagt ich hab gesehen
man kann auch mit papa spiel und klavier
spielen ist doch viel besser
es steht allein er hat eigene beine muss
man ihm nicht halten diese so viel
besser und aus diesem bequemlichkeit
habe ich angefangen klavier zu spielen
ihre eltern waren ja beide auch
musiklehrer und haben sie sehr gefördert
gleichzeitig haben sie auch einmal
erzählt in einem interview hätten ihre
eltern auch nicht versucht so viel
aufhebens um sie zu machen und ihr vater
hätte sie sogar mal in den box
unterricht geschickt zum stil von soll
sich ruhig auch mal eine hand brechen
wenn diese hände so golden sind um nicht
die hände jetzt irgendwie versichern
lassen
der mann war als ich angefangen habe
habe zu spielen sozusagen auf der bühne
war die größte sorge meine eltern dass
ich so normal aufwachsen wie nur möglich
und deswegen nicht was besonderes weil
ich klavierspielen das kind bis zu
dieser extrem dass ich bin dann zu boxen
gegangen aber ich habe auch zum beispiel
schule ganz normal gemacht ich bin ich
finde es schrecklich wenn man begabte
kinder hat man sehr viel musik in sachen
muss man pflegen und nicht viele gehen
dann nicht in der schule haben keine
keine richtige erziehung dass es nicht
gut musik ist auch ein rausch aber es
ist auch ein ausdruck für gleichgewicht
und normalität im leben
das ist ein schöner satz immer du musst
ich länger nachdenken aber interessant
ist ja trotzdem dass sie sich auch
diesen box unterricht dann naja glaube
ich nicht so unglaublich toll fanden
sondern dass sie immer wieder auch das
fußballfeld angezogen hat ist ja
vielleicht auch wenig erstaunlich sind
ja auch argentinia dass sie immer wieder
gern fußball gespielt haben was findet
man auf dem fußballfeld was sie im
orchestergraben nicht finden soll man
nicht vergleichen das also gar nicht
vergleichen ein mann hat so viel gemacht
man sagt gesagt ja intelligent ist wie
ein trainer von fußball
das ist natürlich alles man soll es
nicht vergleichen sind zwei total
unterschiedliche dinge
unser dirigent ist nicht für die fehler
in dem moment wo die mannschaft spielt
hatte seine arbeit gemacht und kann
nicht mehr zu dirigieren kann noch gott
sei dank im konzert noch etwas bewirken
also ist er wie ein regisseur in der
oper gesehen haben sich sehr schwer sie
arbeiten wochenlang doppeln theater
manchmal monatelang und dann kommt die
generalprobe und dann ist aus dann zieht
sie geliefert was die senke oder sie
schauspieler machen ihr könnt ich das
nicht mehr beeinflussen die können alles
vorprogrammieren aber dann und deswegen
ich kenne auch ganz großer regisseure
die nie in den premieren gegangen sind
nicht wie man denken könnte weil sie
unsicher waren oder wollten nicht sehen
wie das publikum reagiert sondern dieses
gefühl von nichts mehr tun können diese
impotenz diese kreative impotenz dass
die arbeit war schon gemacht und jetzt
in die leute geliefert und sie die
regisseure sind abhängig davon von den
willen und die möglichkeiten der
schauspieler oder sänger der geld ist
auch ein bisschen so nicht ich meine ich
kann ja als irgend eine sehr klare idee
haben wie ich eine bestimmte phase wird
obwohl mir vorstellen vorstelle
aber wenn der oboist entweder nicht in
der lage ist so zu spielen oder will
nicht erfüllt das anderes kann ich
nichts tut man spricht immer von die
macht der dirigent dass die agenten mit
der präsident hat keine macht die sägen
kann bestimmen vielleicht manchmal weil
das konzept anfangen soll und zeichnen
geben wie laut oder leise dass gespielt
aber das orchester west affen dürfen
werde die dirigenten noch der
orchestermusiker vergessen sie töne die
musik wird vom orchester gemacht ist der
dirigent kann soviel wirken und tun so
aber es ist wichtig dass sie das nicht
vergessen dass sie sind die
orchestermusiker die wirklich das
musizieren und die töne spielen das ist
gut für das ego des dirigenten klein zu
halten
aber die orchestermusiker müssen auch
daran denken weil sonst reagieren sie
müssen agieren da sie spielen müssen sie
agieren und deswegen ist es sehr wichtig
daran zu denken dass es die musiker im
orchester die spielen aber sie bleiben
dass dirigent natürlich mit dem
orchester auf der bühne ausleben ich
wieder trainer der dann nur am rand
steht herr barenboim kann man eigentlich
dann gegenübers zu hören sprechen auch
der stille zu hören
ich glaube das ist das ist das
vielleicht das wichtigste dass diese
stille hat auch mehrere gesichter nicht
stille bevor der erste ton gespielt wird
ist sie wenn man dieses konzert auch als
zurückgeht wenn man ins konzept geht man
kommt von vier oder so gehetzt und kommt
im letzten moment und des regen und man
siehst du sagst man dort erst mal zur
ruhe zu kommen muss man erst die stille
um dann den klang zu genießen man kann
nicht direkt zum klang gehen ja klar und
die stille bedingen sich auch
gegenseitig und an die stelle innerhalb
des stückes eine pause und einer pause
in eine große steigerungen der musik
danach kommt diese pause die kann noch
laute sein in unserer phantasie als der
lauteste tor davor kann geht nicht mehr
und deswegen bricht alles zusammen und
das bricht alles zusammen das ist so
laut die stille kann ruhe bringen
die stille kann in der musik manchmal
auch die zeit geben ein kleiner achtel
von sekunden würde so irgendwie
unbewusst nachzudenken so was die letzte
phase war die stille ist permanent da
und wir spüren die musik nur wenn wir
spüren die beziehung zwischen die töne
und still
das hat er auch etwas unglaublich
berührendes wenn am ende eines satzes
oder eines konzertes
stille herrscht bevor die leute zu
klatschen beginnen in diesem moment
auszuhalten nicht rein zu klatschen
sondern dieses gemeinsame schweigen und
das nachher muss das ist natürlich
leichter zu bekommen um nicht zu sagen
zu erreichen
weiches stücke diese weise ändern seien
stücke sie mit einem ganz leisen
akkorden und sony music
ein beispiel vielleicht das schluss von
tristan und isolde wenn es zu ende geht
dann ist es vielleicht so werden die
musik sehr aufgeregt ist dann kommt der
applaus aus dem bauch sozusagen das ist
auch okay ich glaube wir sind viel zu
[Musik]
intellektuell über applaus so leute auch
kollegen von mir sind so ist es möglich
zwischen die sätze zu applaudieren
eigentlich warum nicht es war damals
auch so was die komponisten geschrieben
haben natürlich ist besser lief weil man
versucht eine kleine video oder man kann
nicht den emotionelle instinkt immer
versuchen zu intellektualisierung es ist
auch wahr sehr schönes eine spontane
reaktion zu haben
ich finde das sehr sehr wichtig nein
natürlich auch musik gut gefühlt sehr
eng verwoben sind
ein komponist der sich intensiv mit der
frage auseinandergesetzt hat was es
heißt musik und stille irgendwie zu
verweben oder überhaupt stille zu hören
ist die us-amerikaner john cage hat ein
stück geschrieben das heißt vier minuten
33 und ich möchte mit ihnen ein
ausschnitt einer aufführung sehen wir
müssen uns vorstellen die solisten unter
dirigent sind bereits in den konzertsaal
gekommen und applaus sie haben sich
verneigt und jetzt werden noch die
instrumente gestimmt und dann geht's los
[Musik]
herr barenboim was höre ich da bin ich
dieses stück höre ich bin sehr angetan
von dieses stück das man kommentar ist
genau eine weiterentwicklung von dieses
stück stellen sie ich sagte ja absolut
ich das ist doch bescheuert
entschuldigen sie ist man einfach nehmen
beim namen nicht deswegen ich habe
keinen kommentar weil dann wäre ich
irgendwie diese wunderbare stück nicht
gerecht ich sein das stück hat keine
klänge produziert und ich habe keinen
kommentar dazu haben sie sich schon mal
ausgeführt
nein möchten sie auch sprechen wir doch
weiter etwas zu hören es ist ja ganz
klar so dass musiker ein besseres gehör
haben als der durchschnittsmensch
glauben sie musiker können dadurch dass
sie so viel musik machen und hören
müssen einander auch besser zu hören
leider nein
leider nein weil die große mehrheit der
menschen musiker und auch sonst
betrachten die musik als etwas
vielleicht wunderbares schönes und
tiefes und so aber nicht eigentlich das
eigene leben
das gewesen ist vielleicht zwei total
extreme beispiele wie die musik und die
empfindsamkeit nach der musik total
getrennt sind von eigene leben gucken
sie auf einen monster wie adolf hitler
hat millionen von menschen ermordet
sechs millionen juden herein und liebt
er weiß wie viele noch mehr und dass ich
in bayreuth war ich habe ja 18 jahre in
parodiert hat mir sein enkel wolfgang
wagner gezeigt
in der partie verloren wenn der ort wo
der führer immer eine träne im auge
hatte das heißt er hatte wie
empfindsamkeit für die musik weil er
hatte die brille im auge
aber das hat er mit seinem leben
eigentlich nichts zu tun weil jemand der
diese empfindung für etwas schönes und
rührend es müsste eigentlich nicht in
der lage seien an anderen menschen
ermorden
das bleibt total getrennt ist
alljährlich mit mozarts tallinn war so
angetan hat ja auch mehr als 20
millionen menschen
stalin war so angetan von der musik von
mozart sondern hatte eine lieblings
pianistin maria juden eine wunderbare
sowie die pianistin und er hat am abend
am abend in krümmel im rundfunk das
demotiviere konzert gehört wie sie das
spielte und hat sofort anrufen lassen
und wollte sofort eine aufnahme davon
haben und das konzert war übertragen den
rundfunk aber nicht aufgenommen und dann
haben die das ganze orchester die
solistin und der dirigent um mitternacht
im rundfunk saal wieder bestellt die
müssten das alles spielen so dass
tallinn am nächsten morgen um 8 uhr in
krümmel eine aufnahme hat ja so so
verrückt war nach musik und musik war
auch für ihn etwas sehr schön ist aber
es war außerhalb seiner existenz
deswegen glaube ich es ist sehr wichtig
dass man wenn man musik ist dass man
denkt immer an den parallelen zwischen
wie man musiziert und wie man lebt und
es gibt natürlich das problem dass es
gibt keine
bildung erziehung der schulen für kinder
findet halten und dann schon für musik
und man fragt sich eigentlich wieso gibt
es so viele tausende von menschen dann
in den konzerten unser in europa geld
will sie keine vorbereitung dafür haben
und so weiter
gleich wichtig ist es auch dass die
berufliche musiker weiter mit ihrer
bildung machen sie sind konservatorien
der musikhochschule
das wird ja nur musik oft so
instrumental gelernt ja man lernt auch
musiktheorie aber viel weniger
und das heißt jetzt bin ich mensch und
ich unterhalte mich mit in der
angenehmen und der liegt er mag ich
nicht und lasse ich weg und so und jetzt
kommt die musik und die musik ist
außerhalb dieser welt das verstehe ich
aber meine frage war ja eigentlich hop
musiker einander besser zuhören können
dadurch dass sie genau hören können und
sie haben das jetzt ein stück weit
reduziert oder musiker ja die die
musiker sich nicht zwingend so zu sagen
was heißt das denn da man einen also
denke ich mal an ich sage einer person
mit hör mir doch mal zu dann meine ich
ja immer auch so etwas wie bitte
versucht mich zu verstehen also genau
zuhören scheint sehr nahe zu liegen beim
einander verstehen wollen oder zumindest
bemüht zu sein sich zu verstehen
das stimmt wenn wir bei dem mal bleiben
was heißt es musik zu verstehen
vielleicht kann er ja das lernen für
überstehen von menschen natürlich aber
das ist eine fähigkeit die man
haben kann und entwickeln kann muss man
denken viele musiker haben auch eine
musikalische intelligenz der erstaunlich
ist die verstehen die musik um sie
verstehen wie es gebaut ist und wie die
musik hier steigert und wie die
dynamischen kontrasten passieren und die
geschwindigkeit und zeit und raum und
alle diese ideen aber haben nicht eine
ähnliche intelligenz im leben von max
hat sich oft auch zum beispiel senken
ist es noch mehr also noch weniger
verständlich
manchmal beschäftigen sie sich mit
unglaublich wichtige themen bei mozart
bei wagner-opern themen von
menschlichkeit von macht von eros von
grausamkeit von liebe von leidenschaft
und alles nicht und irgendwie kommen das
zu verstehen und das zum ausdruck zu
bringen
aber sie liegt in der lage das
alltägliche leben machen das ist immer
geträumt
das ist schwingt nicht automatisch würde
das heißen
aber etwas was mich beschäftigt ist auch
wenn man ihr buch liest ist die frage
was heißt es eigentlich ein musikstück
zu verstehen und interessant ist er
beispielsweise dass ein musikstück nicht
einfach irgendwie aufhört sondern es
kommt zu einem abschluss musik folgt
einer inneren notwendigkeit und da sind
wir ein stück weit auch bei ihrer großen
begeisterung für den philosophen spinosa
den großen philosophen dem sie ein
ganzes kapitel widmen in ihrem buch und
der die die grundidee der sie nachgehen
ist unter anderem diese dass sie sagen
freiheit ist nicht beliebig sondern
freiheit ist immer die einsicht in eine
notwendigkeit und musik zu verstehen
heißt diese notwendigkeit zu verstehen
blut und können wir davon von dieser
idee
etwas lernen fürs zusammenleben gibt es
notwendigkeiten oder ist die musik
diesbezüglich vielleicht wiederhole ich
mich unsicher weise aber man muss dann
über diese dinge denken
musik kann man leide auch spiel ohne zu
denken es ist ja unterschieden
aber es ist möglich ich kann spielt so
so und ich denke nicht nachkommt ihren
wir aus dem instinkt aus einem
körperlichen etwas tun vielleicht
manchmal auch sozusagen vielleicht gar
nicht so hässlich vielleicht ganz schön
dann verstehen sie was aber denken sie
ist alt ist zum beispiel jetzt haben wir
eine ich empfinde eine konversation sie
und ich das bin ich auch nicht so sie
sprechen und ich hörte dann spreche ich
und sie hören zu
in der musik würden wir das simultan
machen wir würden ein instrument spielen
möchte oder vielleicht vierhändig am
klavier ist egal
aber wir würden das gleichzeitig das
heißt die musik gibt uns die möglichkeit
die beschränkungen die physische
beschränkungen oft zu überwinden
wie können simultan das ist nicht nur
simultan sondern wie sie können die
hauptstimme haben und ich kommentar dazu
gebe sogar manchmal auch subversiv die
musik sehr oft spielt ein instrument die
hauptstimme bei mozart schon das ist
nicht modern und die begleitung ist
subversives macht es macht dich manchmal
lustig über das thema und er unterstützt
ist aber ich weiß nicht was alles also
dass das ist auch die größe der musik
aber ist unser gespräch nicht auch
zweistimmig weil sie sprechen und ich
höre zu aber mein zu hören ist ja auch
teil der melodie dieses gesprächs an
gesprächen jedoch auch zweistimmig ja
das ist der grund dafür
von martin buber der große philosoph für
mich eine der wichtigsten philosophen
des 20 jahrhunderts hat ein buch
geschrieben das ist eine lehre für genau
dieses thema das heißt ich und du
das heißt dass ich existiert allein
nicht existieren weil du existierst und
du hast ein kontakt mit meinem ich genau
und in dieser sessel das ist sehr
wichtig nur in diesem zusammenspiel
kommt auch die erkenntnis wirklich zum
zug
das erinnert mich auch daran dass ich
einmal etwas von ihnen gelesen haben sie
gesagt haben
musik ist technisch gesehen auf einem
enorm hohen niveau angelangt und es gibt
unglaublich gute musiker die technisch
fantastisch sind aber ein stück weit
vermissen sie manchmal das was sie die
geistige dimension der musik nennen was
genau meinen sie mit der geistigen
dimension ist das auch was religiöses
nein nein nein muss ich getan sein aber
muss ich muss ich religiös seien aber
die geister emission hat ist die aussage
warum ist diese musik hier was was was
für eine bedeutung warum weiß so wichtig
für den komponist das zu schreiben
etwas loszuwerden hat nach der es ist
eine wichtige aussage ich weiß etwas das
er unbedingt wollte und so weiter aber
der inhalt der inhalte musik darüber
kann man nicht sprechen weil die musik
ausdruck das was die worte nicht können
und wenn ich das aber ist hat einen
inhalt dass man darüber nicht sprechen
kann heißt nicht dass es nicht existiert
und wenn ich das lernen möchten eben mal
an ich möchte gerne ihr nächstes konzert
besuchen und ich möchte mich vorbereiten
ich möchte auch diese geistige dimension
der musik erfassen die soll ich mich
vorbereiten
das ist sehr schwer für mich zu
beantworten weil ich bin musiker also
ich kann mir das nicht vorstellen ohne
musik und ich kann also ich könnte das
nämlich für ein konzert vorbereiten in
einer art und weise dass ich vielleicht
nicht in der lage sind nämlich dass sich
die partitur nehmen sie studiere und
beobachtet das kann der zuhörer nicht
machen deswegen ist es schwer für mich
ist sozusagen zu beschreiben wie ein
zuhörer sich aber ich glaube dazu hören
muss sich also kann sich vorbereiten
dass sich mehr und mehr gewöhnt als er
hört wirklich und totale konzentration
zuzuhören
ein bisschen wie man ich meine ich mache
keine meditation aber ich habe so oft
mit menschen gesprochen die das machen
und sie müssen irgendwie die ganze
existenz wer haben und dann fangen sie
an zu meditieren und etwas ähnliches
nämlich an passiert beim beim zuhören
eine frage der inneren haltung
innehalten ja sie in erhaltung des zuges
ist genauso wichtig wie die erhaltung
der spielen die musiker nicht wenn man
kommt mit dem problem von zu hause oder
auch mit mit wunderschöne sachen die man
erlebt hat dann ist man nicht in der
lage die musik
wahrzunehmen man nimmt sie als
begleitung instrument aber die musik ich
glaube hat diese möglichkeit uns eine
totale dimension zu geben
wir müssen uns an hängen an dem ersten
klang und dran bleiben und nichts an
andere dinge denken und in den
konzentrationen bleiben und dann die
ganze reise machen und das ist wie ein
klangliches leben
es fängt aus dem nicht an
es endet im nicht dass die geburt und
tod und sie zwischen lang sein ganzes
leben
die spannenden momente in der musik in
dem wir auch auftauchen und und hoffen
auf den next moment sind oft die
chromatischen passagen die sich auflösen
und sie sprechen darüber auch in einer
probe mit der staatskapelle berlin
schauen wir kurz rein zusammen
[Musik]
etwas zur sache zu sagen wir haben ja so
wie schmecken so oft über dieses
chromatisch muss und was das gibt der
musik und dieses format ist muss ich
immer was uns die die die möglichkeit
gibt natürlich in unterschiedliche
richtungen des aufzulösen nicht man sagt
manchmal so ein leben das man in einem
menschlich so ambivalent das hat man
weiß nicht genau was er ist und was er
will und so aber diese ambivalenz sie
sie haben priorität in der musik ist ein
ausdrucksmittel absolut erster klasse
weil es die vier der reibung gibt
unterschiedliche möglichkeiten für sie
gerne einmal dass das zeigen dass
buchstaben ich war elf langsam langsam
das ist ja nur geht
passiert dies nicht wahr so kommt erst
am 1
ok
dann nämlich das nächste mal 49 jetzt
kommen wir in den chromatischen welt 1
[Musik]
was alles ungelöst
weiter
[Musik]
die reibung ist schon zu ertragen nicht
wahr
wie dominant
und da gibt es nur eine lösung und es
ist das
[Musik]
wir sehen uns nach auflösung herr
barenboim in der musik auch im leben
manchmal ja manchmal ja ich finde das
interessant dass ich glaube man hat auch
in dem moment in dem man solche
chromatischen passagen hört und die sich
auflösen
hat man doch dieses gefühl einer großen
erleichterung und ich frage mich
manchmal ist es im leben nicht auch so
dass wir dieses diese auflösung uns
herbeisehnen und gleichzeitig geht es
auch darum wie beim hören von musik
ambivalenzen auszuhalten
diese sie das ist das schönste was sie
sagen könnten weil das zeigt mir dass
sie versuche die verbindung zwischen
musik und leben zu machen das die musik
nicht etwas getrennt ist dass uns
vielleicht vergnügen gibt uns heute aber
es hat ich bin unserem leben zu tun dass
so wie sie es so ich habe sehr früh
angefangen zu spielen ich habe mein
erstes konzert gespielt weil ich sieben
jahre alt und habe auch dann sehr
schnell danach auch sehr große stücke
gespielt und mein vater war mein lehrer
war oft sehr kritisiert ich war elf
jahre alt und spielte später toten
soldaten
wieso glauben sie ihr sohn das also spät
betrieb und salat zu spielen muss man
lebenserfahrung haben usw usw
mein vater hat immer der antwortet ganz
einfach weil die noten in der schublade
bleiben
bringen sie die ist umso man so früh
anfängt umso mehr chancen hat man dann
im leben das zu ausdruck zu bringen
man muss nur die bescheidenheit haben zu
wissen dass man kommt nie an alles man
kann nur etwas mehr lernen das heißt ich
habe eigentlich davon die musik für das
leben gelernt als umgekehrt
weil die meisten menschen mal umgekehrt
ja ich stelle sie ich war ich hatte
schon eine idee von leidenschaft
bevor ich zum ersten mal ein hübsches
mädchen betrachtet habe verstehen sie
was ich meine und ich habe von der musik
deswegen auch für das leben gelernt und
lerne noch immer und da sind wir wieder
bei der frage auch der bindung platon
hatte ja diese idee dass die musik der
perfekte wächter des staates sei leider
musik eindringt in die menschen und sie
durchdringt und sie formt deswegen müsse
man so platten mit der musik sehr
sorgsam umgehen aber sie geben auch
einsätzen in der bildung also könnte man
ja doch sagen wenn ihr musik in schulen
'rein bringen dann kann sie die welt ein
stück weit verändern indem sie die
menschen formt also das ist jetzt meine
große leidenschaft ich möchte alles tun
genau das zu machen und zu schaffen
vielleicht in eine schule spielt
ziemlich weit gekommen ich hoffe
nächstes jahr anfangen zu können
in einer schule ein musik
erziehungsprogramm zu bringen nicht in
eine spezialisierte schule für musiker
sondern das in einer schule und ganz
normale schule volksschule wo man musik
lernen wie man lernt mathematik oder
dann speziell ich dazu und so weiter und
mein traum ist dass es kann so
durchgehen
ich habe vor elf jahren ein
musikkindergarten in berlin gegründet 2
1 in berlin einen in palästina in berlin
und das funktioniert eigentlich sehr gut
und viele kinder machen weiter musik hat
man irgendwie noch im konterspiel
instrument auch wenn sie 14 15 sind und
ich möchte das erreichen dass musik das
kann ich nicht in alle schule machen
aber in einer schule als als wirklich
als experiment sehen wie das
funktionieren kann dass man kann
ein baby schon mit ein jahr kann das
schon im kindergarten gehen und dann ja
eine beziehung zur musik hat sich auch
das spielerisch in der musik der zu
kinder sehr gut passt und sei nur dann
weiter bis die abitur und dann müssen
sich dabei nicht um mehr musiker zu
haben sondern bildung des herzens
irgendwie einfach anzubringen
sie sind ja selber vater von zwei söhnen
beide sind eigentlich musiker geworden
und ist ein berühmter geiger und der
andere ein berühmter dj haben sie beide
gleichermaßen mit musik groß gezogen
oder die sind sie vorgegangen
ja also es muss ich sagen der große ist
hat auch dj gemacht aber es soll eine
elektro pop künstler seine neueste
stücken schreibt ja den text schreibt
die musik sinkt selber und spielt auf
den zins ist das ist sozusagen ein
allround aber wissen sie ich bin der
perfekte beispiel für die tatsache dass
die kinder machen ihre eigene welt beide
kinder sind in gleiche zuhause gewachsen
beide kinder zur gleiche schule gegangen
volksschule in einer internationalen
schule weil die französischen gymnasium
in berlin also genau alles genau das
gleiche gemacht haben das gleiche leben
zu hause erlebt haben und in der schule
auch und sind total anders weil der
wunderbar kinder für mich und sind total
anders auch im charakter und so also das
ist wirklich der beweis dass
man kann es gibt die anlage im kind die
auch einfach ihren ihren gang nicht so
ab sondern kann wirklich die gleiche
botschaft geben man zwei kinder und
jeder macht von dieser botschaft seine
eigene sache und das ist wunderschön
ich freue mich sehr wenn ich das sehe
sie ist das ist meine kinder so
unterschiedlich sind und dass die nicht
versuchen wie eine kopie von den anderen
zu sein sondern haben auch ihre
individualität das ist was sie mir eine
große freude gibt das ist doch schön
einfach dazu haben der raum geht dafür
erbauen waren sie haben vorhin ramallah
erwähnt sie sind ja ein mensch der sich
beruflich aber eben auch menschlich
schon sehr sehr lange einsetzt für den
nahostkonflikt für eine friedliche
lösung für eine vermittlung auch sie
haben 1999 das west eastern divan
orchestra gegründet zusammen mit etwa 2
deinem freund von ihnen
und dieses orchester hat unglaubliches
geleistet unglaublich viele
auszeichnungen gekriegt auch jetzt im
sommer hat das gespielt in luzern am
großen fusion festival und wieder sehr
sehr schnell waren alle karten
ausverkauft das orchester fasziniert
weil in diesem orchester eben einerseits
israelische musiker spielen und
andererseits musiker und musikerinnen
aus den benachbarten arabischen ländern
sie haben immer gesagt sie sind stolz
auf dieses projekt aber es ist kein
politisches projekt für sie warum nicht
weil die politische lösung des konflikts
braucht andere elemente man braucht die
gerechtigkeit für die ballistische sache
was man nicht hat
man dort auch die sicherheit für die
israelische bevölkerung die zwei sind
natürlich gebunden
aber das kann alles ein orchester nicht
machen
total blauäugig das ist ein zeichen dass
heißt ja was ist derzeit was ist die
botschaft von was ist in die wand
orchester außer hat die tatsache dass er
es versucht so gut wie möglich zu
spielen dass es gibt keine militärische
lösung des konflikt für den israelischen
präsidenten prof es gibt keine
militärischen wieso das ist einzige
politische statement dass das orchester
gibt das heißt wir müssen die erzählung
generation das alles wirklich hören uns
respektieren auch wenn wir nicht damit
einverstanden dass respekt zu haben
nur für dinge wo man einverstanden ist
das ist nicht gut diese vielfältigkeit
was vorüber wie so oft in der welt
stecken heute das gibt uns sie die
verantwortung dass er zu machen ich muss
etwas respektieren obwohl ich das anders
sehe ich muss an den menschen
respektieren obwohl sie anders sind als
ich bin oder sein möchte erfahren warum
sie sind 73 jahre alt für 74 da habe ich
ihnen geburtstag verpasst machen sie so
weiter
aber ich wollte sie noch fragen was
möchten sie in ihrem leben unbedingt
noch hören
musik meinen sie ganz egal weil wir das
zuhören und hören gesprochen haben
ich möchte sondern ich kann weiter
musizieren können weil das ist was wir
die größte freude bringt im leben
das wünsche ich ihnen auch ich danke
ihnen ganz herzlich für dieses gespräch
danke dass sie mir zugehört haben danke
dass ich ihnen vor allem zuhören durfte
danke danke schon flüge
ja damit verabschiede ich mich auch von
ihnen daniel fahren wollen können sie
aber noch weiter zu hören und zwar in
der sternstunde musik in einem film der
ihn und sein west eastern divan
orchestra bei den proben begleitet und
zeigt wie es trotz extremer
widerständige linked ein konzert in gaza
zu geben
nächste woche geht es bei uns in der
sternstunde philosophie um den gotthard
und um das pferd zu gast ist ulrich raus
der den langsamen exodus des pferdes aus
der industrialisierten welt
nachgezeichnet hat reiten sie in einer
woche also mit uns mit und genießen sie
jetzt erst mal einen schönen sonntag
[Musik]